yeah defenders sneaking up behind for
turnovers in the quarter faster
[Applause]
Tice called for the foul that's a
technical technical on Boston he's gone
yep
[Applause]
Tice or
as a Boston player fell to the floor and
there was no call I was given a walker
I'll people are throwing gears somebody
just threw a beer that was ridiculous
yeah and securities quickly looked up
there and
making sure the players stay separated
for many of that too
[Applause]
it is Kemba Walker a collision with LA
and the theis ball for the file Stevens
got
[Music]
I know of technicals involved on timber
and I think he was boss I'm not sure
that it is Kim was gone yeah he got
thrown out here he got to ride away I
didn't know it's Steven - gotten one
before that or not don't kill he
immediately came out both on Kimber
there but again Ville listen well that's
a huge huge break for our guys that
could have easily been an offensive foul
right and our guys just have to show
more composure here I mean that's no
Shawn that's what might be a ran into a
611 $265 and he pull any air like he'd
hit an absolute iron walk and he you
know come on yeah well but at first I
thought the same thing
that's hey Bill you hear me complain
about it all the time yeah you know the
fact that you you're actively deceiving
officials and so
note that I've seen Kimball Walker be a
part of that in the past and he got up
and he was so adamant about it being an
offensive foul he had me had me going on
his side which is darn near possible
well and now they're trying to make sure
that the fans are under control here
there was beer thrown I know on the
floor and some of the Spurs players I
saw patty Wills Mills wiping the
something off oh you see that's a water
bottle maybe over here I'm not sure can
regardless inexcusable absolutely
inexcusable that's ridiculous I mean
your team's down seven in the middle of
the third there's so much basketball to
be played and you have somebody that's
got liquored up before the game throwing
beer out in the court and folks if
you're ever in a game and you see
someone doing that
make sure you turn them in
because a few can ruin it yeah for a lot
as far as image and just the way people
live sure
so Aldridge meanwhile plans a movie now
because they've seen the replay
and you would expect them to side on the
case of Kendall of course got that call
gutsy call I got to say that to throw
Kemba Walker out of the game
the other thing Shawn not that this
first wish for anybody to be thrown out
that I feel
about be careful what you wish for kept
the Walker goes out who comes in Marcus
smart yeah he is the guy that could
ignite this team with his passion as you
Kristen play think around
I think the Spurs would not decide they
come out of this his la hit fish pee
we're gonna have to be really strong the
next couple men are no question